This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. The COVID pandemic was terrible in every way, but I had one strange bright spot in my locked-in homebound routine, a weekly Zoom call with the genius director, writer, and producer Ryan Coocler of Black Panther Fruitvale Station and Creed fam. I know, it surprised me too. You're about to learn more about how our relationship got started and our various takes on how we navigate creativity
这里是《99%无形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。新冠大流行在方方面面都糟糕透顶，但在我闭门不出的居家日常中，却有一个奇怪的亮点，那就是每周和天才导演、编剧兼制片人瑞安·库格勒进行一次Zoom通话，他曾执导过《黑豹》、《弗鲁特维尔车站》和《奎迪》。我知道，这也让我很惊讶。接下来你将更多地了解我们的关系是如何开始的，以及我们对如何驾驭创造力的各种看法
and collaboration on this episode of Inproximity, a podcast from Proximity Media, the company he founded with Cindy Cookeler and Seville Hanion. It is a fun conversation with a person I really adore and admire and I thought I could like to hear it. And after you listen, I encourage you to go subscribe to Inproximity because it is a great show, especially if you like learning and thinking about the creative process. So without further ado, here's me being interviewed by Ryan Coogler.
和合作，本期节目来自《Inproximity》，这是Proximity Media旗下的播客，该公司由他和辛辛·库格勒以及塞维尔·汉利翁共同创立。这是一场与我非常喜爱和钦佩的人进行的有趣对话，我想你会喜欢听的。在你听完之后，我鼓励你去订阅《Inproximity》，因为这是一个很棒的节目，特别是如果你喜欢学习和思考创作过程的话。废话不多说，接下来是我接受瑞安·库格勒的采访。
Enjoy. You're listening to PROX. There's a million ways to make something good. I've reached this point where I was like, I think there's the beginning of your career, you feel like you don't know how to make something good. And then the middle of your career, you're like, I'm the only one who knows how to make something good. And you know, it's a perfect way. There's like one way to tell a story. And then later on in your career, you're like, there's a million ways to make something good. And you know, it's a perfect way. There's like one way to tell a story.
尽情享受吧。你正在收听的是PROX。制作好东西有上百万种方法。我达到了这样一个人生阶段，我心想，我觉得在职业生涯的初期，你会觉得自己不知道该怎么做出好东西。而到了职业生涯的中期，你会觉得，我是唯一一个知道怎么做出好东西的人。而且你知道，这是一种完美的方式。讲故事好像只有一种方法。然后到了职业生涯的后期，你会觉得，制作好东西有上百万种方法。而且你知道，这是一种完美的方式。讲故事好像只有一种方法。
And then later on in your career, you're like, there's a million ways to make those good. You're listening to Inproximity. Roman Mars is the host and creator of 99% Invisible, a sound rich narrative podcast about architecture and design. He's also the co-founder of the Independent Podcast Collective, Radio Tobia. In 2021, his team worked with Proximity Media to produce the Judas and the Black Messiah podcast, which helped tell the true story behind the events portrayed in the film.
然后到了职业生涯的后期，你会觉得，把这些东西做好的方法有上百万种。你正在收听的是《Inproximity》。罗曼·马尔斯是《99%无形》的主持人和创作者，这是一档声音丰富的叙事播客，探讨建筑和设计。他还是独立播客联盟Radio Tobia的联合创始人。2021年，他的团队与Proximity Media合作制作了《犹大与黑弥赛亚》播客，帮助讲述了电影中描绘的事件背后的真实故事。
Judas and the Black Messiah is directed by Shaka King and produced by proximity media, macro, Warner Bros and our partners. The story follows FBI informant William O'Neill played by LaKiefe Stanfield as he infiltrates the Illinois Black Panther Party and is tasked with keeping tabs on their charismatic leader, Chairman Fred Hampton, played by Daniel Calaluja in an Oscar-winning performance. On this episode, Roman sits with our
《犹大与黑弥赛亚》由沙卡·金执导，由Proximity Media、MACRO、华纳兄弟和我们的合作伙伴共同制作。故事讲述了由勒凯斯·斯坦菲尔德饰演的FBI线人威廉·奥尼尔，他潜入伊利诺伊州黑豹党，任务是监视他们的魅力领袖弗雷德·汉普顿主席，该角色由丹尼尔·卡卢亚饰演，并凭借此片获得奥斯卡奖。在本期节目中，罗曼与我们的
founder, Ryan Kugler, to talk about what they've learned in leading creative teams, their love of audio storytelling, and their collaboration on the Judas and the Black Messiah podcast. I'm Roman Mars, I'm the hosting creator of the show 99% Invisible. I'm Ryan Kugler, I'm a writer, director, and producer, founder of Proximity Media. Super excited to talk with you, bro. I went back to my email to figure out what the day was that we met. Do you remember what day it was, bro? I just went back and look. I don't remember what day it was.
创始人瑞安·库格勒坐在一起，畅谈他们在领导创意团队方面的收获、对音频叙事的喜爱，以及他们在《犹大与黑弥赛亚》播客上的合作。我是罗曼·马尔斯，我是本节目《99%无形》的主持人和创作者。我是瑞安·库格勒，我是一名编剧、导演兼制片人，也是Proximity Media的创始人。兄弟，我超级兴奋能和你聊天。我翻看了我的邮件，想找出我们相遇到底是哪一天。兄弟，你还记得是哪天吗？我刚刚回去查了一下。我不记得是哪天了。
I mean, I remember where it was. So it was June 9th, 2019. Okay. It was the association of architects. Yeah, the American Institute of Architects. American Institute of Architects, AIA. It was the architecture conference, right? Yep.
我是说，我记得是在哪里。那是2019年6月9日。好吧。是在建筑师协会。对，美国建筑师协会。美国建筑师协会，AIA。那是建筑大会，对吧？是的。
In Las Vegas, I was hosting it and you were the keynote. I was the keynote. You were you're the keynote interview. Like sometimes it's a speaker, but mostly is yeah Yeah, you were the final you're the final act. Yeah. Yeah, it was so cool. What's crazy is like it makes all the station in the world Why you would be here? I thought it would be fun because, you know, I figure, you're asked about a million things when it comes to Black Panther and Marvel and comic books and stuff, but I didn't think that you'd probably ever spent, in like a dedicated half hour talking about the built world
在拉斯维加斯，我是主持人，你是主讲人。我是主讲人。你是——你是主讲嘉宾采访。有时候是个演讲者，但主要是——是的，对。你是压轴——你是压轴节目。对，对。太酷了。最疯狂的是，这让世上所有的——为什么你会在这里？我觉得这会很有趣，因为我知道，当谈到《黑豹》、漫威、漫画书之类的事情时，你会被问到上百万个问题，但我想你大概从来没有花上半个小时的时间，专门来谈论
in some way, but I know you'd thought about it. And so that's where I thought it would be, actually a ton of fun. And I think it turned out to be pretty fun. Now I was great. I had a blast. We were in Vegas, and I remember just being like, really excited to meet you,
某种程度上的建筑世界。但我知道你思考过这个问题。所以这就是为什么我觉得这其实会非常有趣。而且我认为结果确实挺有趣的。我觉得很棒。我玩得超开心。我们在维加斯，我记得当时就觉得，特别高兴能见到你，
because I've been obsessed with podcasts for a long time. And you were there with, it was a few other podcasts that I was there with you. I remember like, right before I went on, I was a little star-struck. Oh, it's kind of you to say. Well, what I loved about it was when we got to Vegas, we talked for like, I don't know, 10, 15 minutes before you went on. And all we did was talk about podcasting.
因为我迷恋播客已经很久了。你在那里，还有其他几个播客也在那里。我记得就在我上台前，我有点追星成功的小激动。噢，你这么说太客气了。不过我最喜欢的是，当我们到了维加斯，在你上台之前，我们聊了大概10、15分钟吧。我们聊的全部都是播客。
You were just like, I like this one. I like this one. Yeah. We're thinking about doing this podcast. All these ideas that you had. And I knew we were just like, he's an apod way to hit it off in terms of podcasting. Yeah. And then like, she got weird with the pandemic and everything.
你当时就说，我喜欢这个。我喜欢那个。是的。我们在考虑做这个播客。你当时有各种各样的想法。我就知道，我们在播客方面绝对是一拍即合。是的。然后呢，大流行期间一切都变得怪异了。
But I remember somehow, I convinced you to do like a meeting per week with me just to like kind of explain how the podcast business works. And it was great. Like we booked it and like we had the time protected. And it got to the point when I was like, really looking forward to it because it was during the pandemic,
但我不知怎么的，我居然说服你每周跟我开一次会，就为了给我解释播客业务是怎么运作的。太棒了。我们把时间定好了，而且把这个时间段空了出来。后来甚至到了这种地步：我真的开始期盼这个会了，因为那是在大流行期间，
when everything was nudge, it was really fun for me too. I mean, we started with you, we were talking about proximity moving into podcasting and I had started my own independent show and I ran an independent label. And that was really fun, but what I remember,
当一切都停滞不前时，对我来说这也真的很有趣。我的意思是，我们从你开始，我们谈到Proximity进军播客领域，而我也创办了自己的独立节目，还运营着一家独立厂牌。那真的很有趣，但我记得的是，
we just had this weekly meeting, it's like five o'clock or something like that. And it was like on a Wednesday or something. Exactly. It was like Wednesday at five. We talked, you know, one or two hours a week, which is more than I talk to, almost anybody. If you ask anybody, there's like,
我们每周都有这个固定的会议，大概在五点钟左右。好像是在周三还是什么时候。没错。就像周三五点。我们聊，你知道，每周一两个小时，这比我跟几乎任何人的聊天时间都要多。如果你去问任何人，他们都会说，
Yeah, that's right. That's a pretty unusual for me. Yeah. But it was totally fun. And what I think I love most about it was, it was fun to talk about podcasting. It was fun to hear about movie making from you, but we would have whole two hour conversations
是的，没错。这对我来说挺不寻常的。是的。但真的非常有趣。而我最喜欢的一点是，聊播客很有趣，听你聊电影制作很有趣，但我们常常会有整整两个小时的对话，
about just like politics and life and our families and our upbringing and stuff like that. It was a real sound for me at a time period where I was suffering from a lack of connection to a lot of people, yeah. It was great, man. One of the things that I admired the most about it was how you kind of like demystified a lot of things
纯粹是关于政治、生活、我们的家庭、我们的成长经历之类的事情。在那个我因缺乏与许多人的联系而备受煎熬的时期，这对我来说真是一剂心灵的良药，是的。太棒了，老兄。其中最让我钦佩的一点是，你如何将许多事情去神秘化，
that I heard about the podcast business. Like one of my favorite things you say was like, your podcast and your radio. You know, I've been doing radio a long time, you know. That unlocked something for me. Because you talk a little bit about how you got started in doing this. Yeah, yeah. I was just someone who loved radio. I was in school to do something else. I was trying
那些我听说过的关于播客行业的传闻。就像你常说的一句我最喜欢的话：你的播客就是广播。你知道的，我做广播很久了，你知道的。这为我打开了新思路。因为你聊了聊你是怎么开始做这个的。对，对。我只是个热爱广播的人。我上学时本打算做别的。我曾经
to be a scientist for a long time. And I listened to NPR in the lab. I loved the way the people talked. I just felt comfortable there. And then there was a certain point where I knew science wasn't for me. My sort of Genesis moment was listening to the show called Talk the Nation. And at the time, Ray Suarez was the host of Talk the Nation. And there was this, there was this episode. It was right around the time of the Clinton scandal with Monica Lewinsky. And the subject of the hour was, if we don't have these type of heroes anymore, who are modern day heroes?
当了很长时间的科学研究员。我在实验室里听NPR（美国国家公共广播电台）。我喜欢人们说话的方式。我在那里感到很自在。然后到了某个时刻，我知道科学并不适合我。我的某种“创世纪”时刻是听了一个叫《Talk the Nation》的节目。当时，雷·苏亚雷斯是《Talk the Nation》的主持人。有那么一期节目，正好赶上克林顿和莫妮卡·莱温斯基的丑闻期间。那小时的主题是：如果我们不再有这种英雄，谁才是现代的英雄？
If the president is fallible and is held accountable for something, who is our modern day heroes? And about midway through the hour, someone calls in and says, you know what, race war is, you're my hero. And I was like sitting there and I was like, you know what, race war is my hero too. I feel like I need to work with Race Wars.
如果总统也是会犯错的，并且要为某事承担责任，那谁才是我们的现代英雄？大约在这一小时过半的时候，有人打电话进来，说：“你知道吗，雷·苏亚雷斯，你是我的英雄。”我当时就坐在那儿心想：“你知道吗，雷·苏亚雷斯也是我的英雄。我觉得我需要和雷·苏亚雷斯一起工作。”
Like I can't do what he does because he just seemed unfathomably good at this to me. But I know that there's a person who reads books and helps him write the questions. And I would be very, very good at that job. That's called a producer, but I didn't write it at the time. So then I began to just sort of like work my life into someone who could be in a position to get a job like that. So I left grad school and moved out here and then that was when I kind of fell in love with radio back then because I couldn't afford a television and listened to the radio all
就像我做不了他做的事，因为在我看来，他在这方面好得深不可测。但我知道有一个人负责读书并帮他写问题。而我非常非常适合那份工作。那叫制片人，但我当时并不知道这个词。于是我开始调整自己的人生，让自己能够处于一个有机会得到那种工作的岗位上。所以我退出了研究生院，搬到了这里，也就是在那时，我开始爱上了当年的广播，因为我买不起电视，总是听收音机。
the time in my drove out to San Francisco in the late 90s, and that's when I sort of began to sort of figure out how to do stories and got a Moran, it's like a cassette recorder, like these big Moran's recorders, and began recording people and trying to figure out what I was gonna do. I began volunteering at Kale W. in San Francisco,
在90年代末，我开车去了旧金山，也就是在那时，我开始琢磨怎么做故事，并弄到了一台Marantz录音机，就像那种巨大的Marantz录音机，开始录制人们的声音，并试图弄清楚我要做什么。我开始在旧金山的KPOO做志愿者，
and I just worked at every type of job that they would let me work, and I basically did it for free, and that just worked at every type of job that they would let me work. I basically did it for free. That's how I started in radio. About this time that storytelling of Ira Glass was sort of entering into this ascendancy, like younger people were becoming more interested in radio as a medium. I just kind of fell into it and never looked back.
我做了他们肯让我做的各种工作，基本上是免费干的，真的做了他们肯让我做的各种工作。基本上是免费干的。这就是我涉足广播的方式。大约在这个时候，艾拉·格拉斯的叙事风格开始崛起，年轻人对广播作为一种媒介越来越感兴趣。我算是机缘巧合加入了这一行，从此再也没有回头。
That's amazing. So were you in college at the time when you had this kind of eureka moment while you were listening to Rice Whereas? I was in grad school. I studied population genetics and plant genetics. And I loved that stuff. Like I loved just finding out what made the world was really interesting to me.
太棒了。所以当你在听雷·苏亚雷斯时，你当时还在上大学，然后有了这种醍醐灌顶的时刻？我在读研究生。我研究的是种群遗传学和植物遗传学。我非常喜欢那些东西。就像我喜欢找出是什么让这个世界运转一样，这对我来说真的非常有趣。
But in the end, I just like knowing that. In short, I processed like a transition in like realizing that you had an idea for your own show and deciding to start it. What was that like? Well, so I had worked on every type of public radio show that you could imagine. It was sort of like hosting some music shows,
但最后，我只是喜欢了解这些。简而言之，你经历了一个转变过程，比如意识到自己有一个制作节目的想法并决定开始。那是什么感觉？好吧，我做过你能想象到的各种类型的公共广播节目。有点像主持一些音乐节目、
storytelling shows. I did my own storytelling show that was local for a while, and that got me the attention of a group called the Third Coast International Audio Festival. I moved to Chicago to work at WBZ for a while. And that got me the attention of a group called the Third Coast International Audio Festival. I moved to Chicago to work at WBZ for a while. And then I was working on a show called Snap Judgment as a senior producer there for a little bit. And then 99% of visible was presented to me as an idea
故事讲述节目。我做过一段时间本地的故事讲述节目，这引起了“第三海岸国际音频节”这个组织的注意。我搬到芝加哥在WBZ工作了一段时间。这引起了“第三海岸国际音频节”这个组织的注意。我搬到芝加哥在WBZ工作了一段时间。然后我在一个叫《Snap Judgment》的节目里做了一小段时间的高级制片人。接着，《99%无形》作为一个创意被摆在了我面前，
of like the AIA chapter in San Francisco was sort of partnering with KLW to figure out would there be a format for a little two-minute insert of a local building to tell a story about? And because of my science education, I've always liked sort of technical subjects, like explaining technical subjects, was always really fascinating to me. And I thought about this as an idea. I knew I wanted to expand it kind of more broadly to not be just buildings, but
那是旧金山的AIA分会与KPOO合作，想弄清楚是否有一种节目形式，可以用两分钟的插播来介绍当地的一座建筑并讲一个故事？由于我的科学背景，我一直很喜欢技术类的主题，比如解释技术类的主题，这对我来说总是非常迷人。我把这当作一个创意。我知道我想把它更广泛地扩展开来，不仅仅局限于建筑物，
just like anything in the built world. My first concept was like curb cuts. When did curb cuts come into being? There's like little ramps that make it so people with different abilities can get from a cross-street essentially. And I was like, I could tell a little story about an everyday thing. And I know that there would be a big story behind what seemed like little decisions.
而是建筑世界里的任何东西。我的第一个概念是关于路缘坡（人行道边缘的坡道）。路缘坡是什么时候出现的？就是那些让不同身体能力的人能够从街角过马路的小坡道。当时我想，我可以讲一个关于日常事物的微小故事。而且我知道，在看似微小的决定的背后，会有一个宏大的故事。
And that was what became 99% invisible. And it was really like an exercise in, could I kind of seduce the audience through like tone of voice and story into caring about things that they pass by every day, that they don't think is interesting. And the challenge of that and the challenge of doing an audio story about a largely visual thing that we experienced like built world design, that was really fun for me.
这就是后来的《99%无形》。这其实是一种练习，看我能否通过声调和故事来“诱惑”观众，让他们去关心那些他们每天路过、却觉得索然无味的事物。这种挑战，以及如何用音频故事来讲述我们所经历的、主要是视觉维度的东西——比如建筑世界设计，对我来说真的非常有趣。
Man, what was it like you transitioned to being a business owner in multiple Google's bosses like wow, and still being an artist? Like how did you find that? How do you find it today? I like that my job always changes. So inside of radio, there's this thing called a producer. And a producer is I think the highest form of worker
老兄，当你转型成为一个多重谷歌老板式的人物（注：此处口误，可能指GooGoo's bosses或类似词汇，意为身兼数职的老板），同时又依然是一名艺术家时，那是什么感觉？你是怎么找到这种平衡的？你现在又是如何看待它的？我喜欢我的工作一直在变。所以在广播行业内部，有一个职位叫制片人。而我认为制片人是最高形态的工作者
and human that there is. A producer is a person who just will solve any problem to get the thing on the air or like available for someone to download. And that could be just like you do interviews, you write, you edit things, you do whatever it takes to get a thing done. And that's what a producer is. And that's why they're like the highest form of worker because they will really do anything to make something happen. And to me, as the job changed, and my job was as much about making sure the people under me were paid. Right. I liked solving that problem.
也是最高形态的人类。制片人就是那种为了让节目顺利播出、或者让大家能够下载收听，愿意解决任何问题的人。这可能包括做采访、写作、剪辑、做任何能把事情搞定的事情。这就是制片人。正因如此，他们才是最高形态的工作者，因为他们真的会为了让事情发生而付出一切。对我来说，随着工作内容的改变，我的工作同样包括确保我手下的人能拿到薪水。没错。我喜欢解决这个问题。
As much as I love to be in pro tools and I love to interview people and stuff like this, I got a real thrill out of like building something from scratch and making sure payroll was made. The flip side of like enjoying to do everything is you end up doing everything and it's harder to let some of that stuff go. I'm way better at that now because I have people on my team, you know, you know this, it's like they're better at me than things,
就像我热爱使用Protools、热爱采访别人一样，从零开始搭建一个团队并确保按时发薪水，这让我感到由衷的刺激。享受亲力亲为的另一面是，最后你什么都自己干，而要放手其中一些事情就变得更加困难了。我现在在这方面做得好多了，因为我团队里的人——你知道的，你也懂——他们比我更擅长某些事情，
you know, like it's like they're just better and you just like, you job is just to get out of the way. Totally. And so like that part took me more time because you know, it takes a while to bring someone in and like show them a thing and they take twice as long as you do and you just wanna like, I'll just give it to me, you know, like,
你知道，他们就是更厉害，而你的工作就是别挡道。完全同意。所以这部分花了我更多时间，因为你知道，把一个人招进来并向他们展示一件事需要时间，他们花的时间会是你的两倍，而你只想——“还是交给我吧”，你知道，诸如此类。
and that sort of thing. I actually thought to myself the other day, because you know, when you first get started as a filmmaker, you got a film school and everything, you did editor, you did cinematographer, you know, you first get started as a film maker you got a film school and everything you did editor You did cinematographer, you know you hold the boom you doing your mix and pro tools I used to know all of these things and I used to be like fairly good at all of them and I was thinking about it now Like I'm like fuck out dropped off somewhere and it was like I am a makeup movie. I don't think I could do it Because like all of all of the muscles. I think of like kind of atrophy
我前几天其实还在想，因为你知道，当你刚开始做电影制作人时，你去了电影学校之类的，你做过剪辑师、摄影师，你知道的，当你刚开始做电影制作人时，你去了电影学校之类的，你做过剪辑师、摄影师，你知道的，你扛过话筒杆，自己在Pro Tools里做混音。我以前懂所有这些，而且我以前对所有这些都相当擅长。我当时在想，现在我觉得有些技能不知道丢到哪里去了，当时的感觉就像：“我是个拍电影的。我觉得我可能做不到了。”因为所有的——所有的肌肉，我觉得都萎缩了，
You know to the point where I'm like, am I just useless now? You know, like, I feel that way all the time. It's interesting too, because like, you talk about like a producer being like the highest form of functioning human on a project. Like, in a way, direct is almost the opposite sometimes, it feels like, like, if you got like a real, well functioning set, you got like, good actors, you could kind of like, not do anything. The movie is still happening in a way you know saying like yeah
你知道的，到了那种地步，我会想：“我现在是不是变成废物了？”你知道，我时常会有这种感觉。这也很有趣，因为当你谈到制片人是一个项目中功能最强大的最高形态人类时，从某种意义上说，导演有时恰恰相反，感觉像是，如果你有一个运转良好的片场，有一群优秀的演员，你甚至可以什么都不做。电影还是在进行，你知道我在说什么吗？是的。
I had days on set where I felt like really like insignificant you know saying like just because so much is being delegated at this point I relate to that what you talking about I know that feeling like I used to mix and be the final mixer on every episode of the show In the beginning really was just me and then it quickly became more and more and more people. Now, I don't think Martín González, who's our, you know, sounded here, I don't think I could even understand the busing and processing he does to the sound anymore. Like, I don't think I could even open it up
我在片场有时候会觉得自己真的无足轻重，你知道的，因为那时候有太多事情都被委派出去了。我能理解你的感受，我懂你在说什么，我明白那种感觉——就像我以前包办每一集的混音，是节目的最后混音师。一开始真的只有我一个人，但很快人数就越来越多。现在，我不觉得马丁·冈萨雷斯（Martin González）——我们的音响师——做的那些针对声音的总线和处理，我还能完全听懂了。我觉得我甚至都没法打开那个工程文件
and really get it. You know, and he just have to just let it. Like, I used to think that this would be like, a spiritual death on my part, you know, to me not know how the show worked And now it's just like you just sort of ease into it like freezing the death or I think that's a that's really interesting so look like Was great about our relationship was like we didn't just talk about things.
去真正弄明白。你知道的，你只能选择放手。以前我总觉得，如果自己搞不懂节目是怎么运作的，就像是在精神上死了一回一样。但现在，你就慢慢适应了，就像慢慢冻死那样……我觉得这真的很有意思。所以，我们关系最棒的地方在于，我们不只是在空谈。
Like we actually got to make something together, you know. That was really like profoundly exciting for me. It was honestly like what I liked a lot about you was that we would talk, but it was very clear to me that I was talking to another person who was a doer, you know. It wasn't just like pipe dreams. Like if we had the opportunity to work on something and do something together Like I had this feeling like it would actually happen And we got that opportunity with the Judas and Black Messiah podcast
而是我们真的有机会一起做出点东西来，你知道的。这对我来说真的是一种深刻的兴奋。老实说，我很欣赏你的一点是，我们虽然在聊天，但我很清楚，坐在我面前的是另一个“行动派”，你知道的。这不只是空想。如果我们有机会一起合作、一起搞点什么，我有种强烈的预感——这事儿真的能成。而我们通过《犹大与黑弥赛亚》播客就得到了这个机会。
Yeah, it was our first time as a company making something in audio This is before we hired the great Paul Amardo who runs that division for us We were like outsourcing it to you guys, you know to make it plain. I just found a process like exhilarating. So one of the proximity media's first films was Judas in the Black Messiah, which was co-written and directed by Shaka King, and I was fortunate enough to be a producer on it along with my partners, Sebal Hanian and Zizi Kugler. It was an incredible process, but we also had a campaign podcast to the film, which was narrated by Elvis Mitchell
对，那是我们公司第一次制作音频内容。这还是在我们雇佣了负责那一部门的伟人保罗·阿马多（Paul Amardo）之前。当时我们是把这块外包给你们的，直说吧。我发现整个过程简直让人兴奋不已。Proximity Media早期的电影之一就是《犹大与黑弥赛亚》，由沙卡·金（Shaka King）联合编剧并执导，我很幸运能和我的合伙人瑟巴尔·哈尼安（Sebal Hanian）以及齐齐·库格勒（Zizi Kugler）一起担任制片人。这是一个不可思议的过程，但我们当时还为这部电影制作了一个配套播客，由埃尔维斯·米奇尔（Elvis Mitchell）担任旁白，
and produced by Roman Mars, Christopher Johnson, and the team at 99% and visible. And it was a companion piece to the film that really went into the making of it, but through the eyes of Chairman Fred Hampton's son, Chairman Fred Hampton Jr. and it was a really moving experience getting the make the podcast.
由罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）、克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）以及99% Invisible团队共同制作。这是电影的衍生伴读内容，真正深入探讨了电影的幕后制作，但视角是通过主席弗雷德·汉普顿的儿子——小弗雷德·汉普顿主席（Chairman Fred Hampton Jr.）的眼睛展开的。制作这个播客是一次非常感人的经历。
Specifically, I remember when we were talking about the show and trying to figure out like if there was a show there and like what may have since, we spoke for a long time, I blabbed a lot about the process, what was going on and how it was clear to us that the show would be helpful in terms of Chairman Fred Hampton Jr. Talking about the film and really like, we looked at it as like a campaign piece that could help him and his mother and mother of a cool process. What it's like to have this person's story told through a magic motion picture that affected their lives, you know.
特别是，我还记得当我们讨论这个节目、试图弄清楚它到底有没有戏、成不成型时，我们聊了很久。我喋喋不休地讲了很多制作流程、进展情况，以及我们为什么觉得这个节目会很有帮助——从小主席弗雷德·汉普顿谈论这部电影的角度来看。我们真的把它当作一个宣传造势的项目，希望能对他、他的母亲以及库拉妈妈（Mother Akua）有所帮助。讲述这样一个人的故事是怎样一种体验：通过一部影响了他们生活的神奇电影，
His father, that political leader, and you said something I was really incredible. You kind of boiled down to a sentence and you said, this show should be about a guy who's trying to protect his father's legacy. And it was like boom, like I understood it. And filmmaking terms, I got my protagonist, you know what I'm saying? I got the action that they're trying to do. And now I'm on the hook is it will they won't they? You know what I mean? And I thought that was just fantastic. Well, I just wanted to be involved because there was a real reason for the Judas in the Black Messiah podcast to exist, because there was a person there in Chairman Jr. who had something to say,
把他的父亲——那个政治领袖的故事呈现出来。然后你说了句让我觉得非常了不起的话。你把它精简成了一句话，你说：“这个节目应该讲的是一个试图守护他父亲遗产的男人。”当时的感觉就像“轰”的一下，我全懂了。用电影术语来说，我找到了我的主角，你知道我的意思吗？我找到了他们试图去完成的行动。现在我被悬念套牢了：他们能成功吗？还是不能？你知道我的意思吗？我觉得这真是太棒了。嗯，我只是想参与其中，因为《犹大与黑弥赛亚》播客的诞生有一个真正的理由，因为小主席这个人有话要说，
who because of the necessity of two hour film, dramatic entertainment, can't have everything in it. Like it just can't. People have to streamline, people have to be combined. You know, like it, can't have everything in it. Like it just can't. People have to streamline, people have to be combined, you know, like it's just the way it is. And you have very real limitations at a medium. I mean, it's incredible. You can tell so much more, like in a single image, it tells so much, but also just like,
但由于两小时电影的时长限制和戏剧娱乐的需求，不可能把所有东西都塞进去。就是塞不下。人们必须精简，人们必须合并，你知道的，就是塞不进所有东西。它真的做不到。人们必须精简，人们必须进行剪辑合并，你知道的，现状就是这样。而且你在媒介上有着非常现实的限制。我的意思是，这真的很神奇，你可以在一个单一的镜头里表达很多东西，它包含的信息量巨大；但同时，
there's a way that people watch things that you just can't cram in all those details, the way you can in a conversation that people follow. And, you know, so I loved the challenge of it. And I loved that it just had, you know, like I'm a design guy. Like to me, like things have to have a reason to exist. They can't just exist to be filigree or extra or promotion. Like this was a companion that I thought moved the story forward in a way. In term in like needed production, like he had so much to say that it was like,
人们观看事物的方式，决定了你无法像在一段人们能够一路跟随的对话中那样，塞进所有这些细节。所以，我热爱这种挑战。我也很喜欢它有着……你知道的，我是一个注重设计的人。对我来说，任何事物都必须有存在的理由。它们不能为了存在而存在，不能只是花边装饰、冗余或纯粹的宣传。我认为这是一个能以某种方式推动故事发展的伴随之作。在需要的制作方面，他有太多话要说了，以至于当时我们在想：
okay, so how do we order this? Like how do we think about this? How do we think about Mama Kua and how we think about the fact that he meets this person playing his dad who he never really met. You know, all that sort of stuff was so, like, intense and interesting. And, like, he had these insights about filmmaking
“好吧，那我们该如何梳理这些内容呢？我们该如何看待这一切？我们该如何看待库拉妈妈，以及他与那个扮演他从未真正谋面的父亲的演员见面这件事？”所有这些类似的事情都是如此强烈、如此有趣。而且，他对电影制作有着独特的见解，
that were so interesting to me to kind of listen in on. I should stress here that Christopher Johnson produced this thing. I'd like, you know what I mean? Like, like, a little bit. Yeah. I brought in Christopher Johnson to make the thing. Shout out to Christopher.
听他分享这些真的让我觉得非常有趣。我在这里得强调一下，克里斯托弗·约翰逊制作了这个节目。你知道我的意思吧？差不多就是这样。我把克里斯托弗找来做这个项目的。向克里斯托弗致敬。
Yeah. But like Chairman Jr., have these insights like on set about just the sort of blocking of like having this white supremacist standing over his father and his like his father would never do that. And it's like these things are like, yep, that's right. Yeah. It took someone like that and having that conversation
对。但就像小主席在片场提出的一些见解，关于分镜调度（blocking）的安排——比如有个白人至上主义者站在他父亲身旁，而他父亲绝不会那样做——诸如此类的事情，大家都会说：“对，就是这样。”没错。能有这样一个人，并且能进行这样的对话，
was just really, really interesting. And your partners at Warner Brothers were really good about letting him be critical and have it be genuine. I was impressed by that. There was just like, it was a cool problem to solve of like, how do you make a companion where this person like really has like things to say and not all of them are like, this is great.
真的非常非常有意思。你们在华纳兄弟的合作伙伴真的很开明，允许他进行批评，并保持真实感。这让我印象深刻。这就像是一个很酷的难题需要解决：你如何制作一个伴随性的内容，让这个人能够真正表达自己的想法，而且其中有些内容并不是那种“这太棒了”的盲目吹捧。
You know what I'm gonna say? Yeah, yeah, and it just felt like it was interesting because we were the obstacle. You know what I mean? And that log line is like, hey, you know, this is about a guy trying to protect his father's legacy, like what's implied there is, he's trying to protect it from any kind of missteps
你知道我要说什么吗？对，对，而且这感觉很有趣，因为我们（电影方）其实就是他面前的阻碍。你知道我的意思吗？那句故事大纲就像是：“嘿，你知道的，这是一个男人试图保护他父亲遗产的故事。”这里面隐含的意思是：他正试图从我们在电影中
we will make in the film. You know what I'm saying? He's trying to detect it from this system that has to flatten things in order to do his job. It came together. It was a remarkable piece of journalism. But what I remember, one of my finest memories was, I can't remember what exactly the term is,
可能会犯的任何失误中保护它。你知道我的意思吗？他试图从这个为了完成其工作而不得不将复杂事物扁平化的体制中保护它。最终这一切凝聚在了一起。这是一篇卓越的新闻报道。但我记得，我最美好的回忆之一——我记不清具体该怎么称呼那个术语了，
you got to call it, but it was like when you guys had to script up on a gold dock and just kind of like we were listening to it, you had all your folks kind of like chiming in and the notes. Yeah, yeah. We call that a read to tape. It's like a table read. We call it read to tape. So we have all the clips out. We have like your parts.
你们管它叫什么来着？就是当你们把剧本弄到音频文稿上（on a gold dock），然后我们一起听的时候，你们所有人都七嘴八舌地提出各种意见和修改意见。对，对。我们管那叫“对白到带”（read to tape）。这就像是一次剧本围读。我们把它叫做“对白到带”。所以我们会把所有的音频片段都整理出来。里面有你的部分，
Christopher Red, Elvis's parts. You know, I would read some of them. And then we have the tape. And then there's all these sort of notes in the margins. So like if there's a mess up, we just keep going. You know, and everyone makes little notes in the margin. And I remember we invited you to it. And I remember this very cutely because I said, you know, we do this for like three hours.
克里斯托弗念的部分，埃尔维斯的部分。你知道的，我会读其中的一部分。然后我们播放原始录音带。接着页面空白处会有各种各样的修改意见。所以如果哪里说错了，我们直接继续往下录，你知道的。每个人都会在空白处做小笔记。我记得我们邀请了你来参加。我对这件事记忆犹新，因为当时我说：“你知道的，我们要搞这个大概三个小时，
It's long, it's tedious. We go over every little word it phrase, and it might be really boring. And you said to me, I look at a guy picking up a coffee cup 30 times to figure out which one I'm going to use. There is nothing too boring for me. It's like six thousand dollars of a coffee cup. Oh yeah. It's a true story.
又长又枯燥。我们要字斟句酌地过每一个词每一句，可能会非常无聊。”而你对我说：“我为了决定最终采用哪一个，可以看一个人拿咖啡杯拿30次。对我来说没有什么是太无聊的。”就好像为了一个咖啡杯花了六千美元一样。哦对。这是个真实的故事。
And so yeah, and that was really delightful. And it's the moment you know, it's coming to life. Like there's a, you know, I recommend when anyone makes a thing. It's very important to have these, to experience it with other people, because you feel the slow parts, the parts that just embarrass you, the parts that you feel them when people are next to you that you don't feel it by yourself. You have to have these moments of sharing little bits of it. Because to me, my ears get hot,
所以，是的，那真的让人感到非常愉悦。这就是你知道事物正在被赋予生命的时刻。我是说，我建议任何人做东西的时候，经历这个过程、与其他人一起体验是非常重要的，因为你会感受到那些冷场的部分，那些让你感到尴尬的部分，当身边有别人的时候，你会真切地感受到这些，而如果只有你一个人是感受不到的。你必须经历这些分享点滴碎片的时刻。因为对我来说，我一听到就会耳朵发烫，
I get embarrassed about it, and I want that for you to go away so badly. So I go in and fix it. Oh yeah. No, 100% man, I really enjoyed that process. I got this theory, I'm getting more evidence of it the other I get is that nobody really knows what anybody's job is like.
我会为此感到尴尬，而我极其渴望这种感觉消失。所以我就会进去把问题修复好。哦对。不，百分之百，老兄，我真的很享受那个过程。我有一个理论，随着我年龄越来越大，我得到了越来越多的证据，那就是没有人真正知道别人的工作到底是怎样的。
You know what I'm saying? Like, and you got no idea. You're opening up your mailbox and your mail is there. You got no idea how I got there. What it took, you know. And that you can't really appreciate something until you understand what went into it. And most things you'll never know.
你知道我的意思吗？就像，你毫无头绪。你打开信箱，邮件就在里面。你根本不知道它是怎么到那儿去的，为此付出了什么，你知道吗。在你明白这一切凝聚了多少心血之前，你其实是无法真正欣赏某样东西的。而且大多数事情你永远都不会知道。
I remember being on that call with you all and seeing everybody like thinking so deeply considering everywhere, questioning things. I thought like, yes, this makes sense. I love it, this much care is going into this thing. And I love that, this is how these things are made. You know what I mean? Like these podcasts, I'll listen to these radio stories,
我记得当时和你们所有人一起开电话会议，看到每个人都在深入思考、斟酌每一个地方、质疑各种事情。当时我想：是的，这讲得通，我太喜欢了，竟然有这么多的关切被倾注到这个项目里。我喜欢这一点，这些东西就是这样被制作出来的。你知道我的意思吗？就像这些播客，我会听这些广播故事，
I'll listen to these, whether it's 15 minutes or 20 minutes, seeing that process, and knowing that it's something that's been developed over time, I gotta imagine that system, that reads the type system. How long would you say that system's been around? Romantic like, oh for, I mean for me, the thing was, I did so much of it by myself for a long time, that there was no one to kind of work with. But like as soon as we had more than three people, we began doing it.
我会听这些——不管是15分钟还是20分钟的节目，看到这个制作过程，知道这是经过时间沉淀慢慢打磨出来的东西，我简直无法想象那个系统——那个“对白到带”的系统。你觉得这个系统存在多久了？罗曼，哦，就我而言，情况是这样的：在很长一段时间里，大部分活都是我一个人干的，所以根本没有其他人可以合作。但一旦我们有了三个人以上，我们就开始这么做了。
And I knew other shows do it, or maybe they, you know, it's not uncommon to instead record it, or record scratch tracks of it, and just send it around for notes and stuff like this. But I find something really good comes out in the moment, doing it live, you learn things, and you learn, you know, especially because like someone's writing for me, like in those situations, I mean, not on Judas, but like on 99, they're writing
我知道其他节目也会这么做，或者也许它们……你知道的，把内容录下来或者先录个粗剪版（scratch tracks），然后发给大家收集意见之类的事情并不少见。但我发现，在现场实时进行这种操作，往往能迸发出非常棒的东西。你会在其中学到东西，并且你会发现——尤其是因为有人在为我写稿子，在那种情况下（当然不是指《犹大》这个项目，而是指《99%》这样的节目），他们会写出
a thing that needs to be said for me to say. And then I would go, well, I think I'd say a little differently here or that's really, you know, they sometimes I really capture my voice or make a joke or sometimes a joke comes out through that process. And I've always sort of felt like what I liked about the format of Nine-Names and I'm visible because I kind of am there as a host like interjecting kind of all the time was that I wanted the opportunity to you know to react and someone says a thing and rather than just let it sort of sit there, everyone's thinking the same thing so it would be fun just to say it you, like, and so we figured that out for our show. And it's just, I mean, it's like the best part of my day.
需要我去念的台词。然后我就会说：“嗯，我觉得在这里我可能会换一种说法”或者“这真的很……”你知道的，有时候他们真的捕捉到了我的声音特点，或者抖了个包袱，或者有时一个笑话正是在这个过程中自然诞生的。我一直觉得，我之所以喜欢《99% Invisible》这种形式——因为我作为主持人一直都在不断地插话——是因为我想要有机会做出反应。当别人说了一句话的时候，与其让它就那么晾在那里（其实大家心里想的都一样），不如直接把它说出来，这会很有趣。所以我们为自己的节目找到了这种感觉。我的意思是，这简直是我一天中最美好的时光。
We do probably one of those a week. And sometimes it's hard, but like, you know, you've cracked it. But it's just like, that's the, I, you know, I sit, and now it's like sitting in a Zoom with like six or seven other people. I'm like hearing their work for the first time and seeing it come together and seeing them take big swings and seeing some of them connect and some of them don't.
我们大概一周会做一次这样的会议。有时过程很艰难，但你知道的，一旦你找到了诀窍……这就是……你知道，我坐在那儿，现在就像是在Zoom里和另外六七个人一起开会。我第一次听到他们的作品，看着它一点点成型，看着他们做出大胆的尝试，看着其中一些尝试取得了成功，而另一些则没有。
It's just, I just recommend that you like get a group together and get a good group of people and help them be your editors because no one has that good a taste or that good of instincts. Like there's a million ways to make something good. Like, I've reached this point where I was like, I think there's the beginning of your career, you feel like you don't know how to make something good.
我真的建议大家组建一个团队，找一群优秀的人，让他们来当你的编辑，因为没有任何人的品味或直觉能完美到那种地步。把事情做好的方法有成千上万种。就像，我已经达到了这样一个阶段：我觉得在职业生涯的初期，你会觉得自己根本不知道该怎么把东西做好。
And then the middle of your career, you're like, I'm the only one who knows how to make something good. And you know the perfect way. There's like one way to tell a story. And then, later on in your career, you're like, there's a million ways to make this good. Like I've heard and seen people do it so good. And you could do it differently or you could choose this one or you could say it this way. You just have
然后在职业生涯的中期，你会觉得：“我是唯一知道怎么把东西做好的人，我知道最完美的方式。”仿佛讲故事只有唯一的一种正确方法。再到后来，在职业生涯的后期，你会意识到：“要把这东西做好，方法有成千上万种。”我听过也见过别人把事情做得极其出色。你可以换一种方式去做，或者你可以选择这一种，或者你可以这样表达。你只需要
to write your way out of it to make it make sense for the audience and you're serving an audience. But there's like a million ways to make a good radio story. There's a million ways to make a good movie. Absolutely. And so once you sort of get into that zone, you allow people to like, to try lots of different things that you would never try. I mean, that is like, heaven as a creator,
通过文字创作杀出重围，让它对受众来说合情合理，因为你是在为受众服务。但是，要做出一个好的广播故事，方法有千万种；要拍出一部好电影，方法也有千万种。绝对是这样。所以一旦你进入了那种状态，你就会允许大家去尝试各种你平时绝不会去尝试的不同事物。我的意思是，对一个创作者来说，这简直就像天堂一般，
is to have a team around you who brings you things that just blow you away. You know, I feel like that when I produce for other directors. You know what I mean? Like, we're talking about Judas. I thought I'd like that when I produce for other directors. You know what I mean? Like we're talking about Judas. I thought I'd that with Shaka like every day. It was like, yeah, I would never make this choice. But it's a perfect choice.
身边有一支团队，能不断带给你那些让你惊艳不已的东西。你知道的，当我为其他导演担任制片人时，我也有这种感觉。你知道我的意思吗？我们刚才在聊《犹大》。我觉得当我为其他导演担任制片人时也是这样。你知道我的意思吗？我们当时在聊《犹大》时，我和沙卡每天都有这种感觉。当时我就想：是的，我绝对不会做出这种选择。但这绝对是一个完美的选择。
And I get to be around you. I totally was fantastic. When I liked about working with you on Judas and all that sort of stuff and those conversations we had was like, you had other things to do. I mean, you were writing what kind of forever at the time. You had a lot going on.
而且我能和你在一起共事，这真的太棒了。在《犹大》的项目中以及在我们的那些对话中，我最喜欢你的一点是，你当时手里还有别的事要忙。我的意思是，你当时正在写《黑豹》（kind of 泛指《黑豹》Forever）的剧本。你有很多事情要处理。
Yeah. But like, no part of the podcast process was uninteresting to you. It was, I love it, man. I feel fortunate to be involved, man. It was like a dream of mine. You know, like to make a podcast in general, because I think the medium is so fascinating.
对。但播客制作过程中的任何一部分对你来说都不是无聊的。相反，我爱死它了，老兄。我觉得自己能参与其中非常幸运，老兄。这就像是我的一个梦想。你知道的，制作一档播客，因为我觉得这种媒介太迷人了。
It still is fascinating to me, man. I'll see stuff we had a meeting this morning with some stuff Paula was doing, and I was like, man, it's so cool, and it has similarities to what we do as filmmakers. But at the same time, it is very different. It requires another form of thinking, dude, I love it, man.
直到现在它对我也依然充满魅力，老兄。我看到我们做的一些东西——今天早上我们还开会讨论了保拉（Paula）在做的一些内容——当时我就想：“天哪，这太酷了，它和我们作为电影人所做的事情有相似之处。”但与此同时，它又非常不同。它需要另一种形式的思维模式，老兄，我爱死这个了。
It's few things I love as much as that specific medium. So for my prox rec, I'm gonna take the easy way out and I'm gonna recommend Roman's book to 99% of his city. I like that. I think that it's a great book, a great piece of art and it's really cool for me because you know obviously Roman makes audio. It was great for me to have a physical thing. I kind of see I was almost like a campaign if you're a fan of the show.
很少有什么东西能像这种特定的媒介那样让我如此热爱。所以对于我的Proximity推荐（prox rec），我要走一条轻松的路，我推荐罗曼关于《99% Invisible》的书。我很喜欢这个。我觉得这是一本好书，是一件伟大的艺术品，对我来说真的很酷，因为显然罗曼做的是音频。对我而言，能有一个实体的东西感觉很棒。如果我是节目的粉丝，我几乎会把它看作是一次宣传造势。
But it's a lot of great work in there. A lot of great work of journalism in art. It makes you great coffee table with addition. You know what I mean? It looks great on a bookshelf. You know they press your friends. They come over and I see it. That's my prox wreck for today.
但里面有大量出色的工作成果。那是新闻业与艺术的伟大结晶。它能成为一本极棒的咖啡桌读物，你知道我的意思吗？放在书架上看起来太棒了。你知道的，这能给来访的朋友留下深刻印象。他们走过来就能看到它。这就是我今天的Proximity推荐。
Yeah, and I should add that I wrote parts of that. But my co-author Kurt Coles that who, like honestly, if he didn't work on that book, that book would have never gotten done. So he's a real driving force behind the book, but I thank you so much. That means the world to me. I guess if you're interested in the craft of radio making, audio making, I think few places are more thoughtful than the website, transome.org. You could learn a ton and how people make things understand what they're doing,
是的，我得补充一下，那本书的部分内容是我写的。但我的合著者库尔特·科尔斯，说实话，如果不是他参与那本书的工作，那本书根本不可能完成。所以他是这本书背后的真正推动力，但我非常感谢你。这对意义重大。我想如果你对广播制作、音频制作的工艺感兴趣，我想没有哪个地方比网站 transome.org 更注重深思熟虑了。你可以学到很多东西，了解人们是如何制作东西的，理解他们在做什么，
like, what does it imply when like you have music and the music goes out. And then the next thing you say, like all of a sudden becomes very important. You're like learning tricks like this that you pick up on, but you just don't, you probably never really saw them articulated or heard them in such a way that you got what the emotion was And that's the same things that I'm sure you learn in like film school and stuff like this is like this is what this does This is what this cut does you know speeding up the I don't know the edits You know like do this of a rhythm, you know, so like that. Yes, a language you call it the language You're sending with every art form has its language. Totally. And so the audio, like the best people
比如，当你有音乐而音乐淡出时，这暗示了什么。然后你说的下一件事，突然变得非常重要。你就像是在学习这样的技巧，你注意到了它们，但你可能从来没有真正看到它们被清晰地表达出来，或者以那种让你理解其情感的方式听到它们。我确信你在电影学院等地方学到的也是同样的事情，比如这就是这个动作的作用，这就是这个剪辑的作用，你知道的，加快……我不知道，剪辑速度，你知道的，按照这种节奏来做，你知道的，就像那样。是的，一种语言，你称之为语言。你随身携带的每种艺术形式都有它的语言。完全同意。所以，音频，就像最优秀的人一样
for breaking that down to understanding how to do a type of audio storytelling is transom.org and I'd really recommend it. And the other thing I recommend is just like listening to things, I like everything. Roman, I wanna thank you for being on our show in Proximity. It means the world that you made time
剖析这一点，理解如何进行某种音频讲故事的最佳去处是 transom.org，我真的很推荐它。我推荐的另一件事就是听各种东西，我什么都喜欢。罗曼，我想感谢你参加我们的节目《In Proximity》。你能抽出时间，这对我们意义重大
and I think Fox really enjoyed what you have to say. So thank you, bro. Oh, it's my pleasure. It was a real honor. It's a real honor. It's a real honor. It's a real honor. It's a real honor.
我想福克斯真的很喜欢你的分享。所以谢谢你，兄弟。哦，这是我的荣幸。这真的是个荣幸。这真的是个荣幸。这真的是个荣幸。这真的是个荣幸。
It's a real honor. It's a real honor. It's a real honor. It's a real honor. It's a real honor. It's a real honor. In Proximity is a production of Proximity Media. If you like the show, be sure to follow, rate, and review it on Apple podcasts, Spotify,
这真的是个荣幸。这真的是个荣幸。这真的是个荣幸。这真的是个荣幸。这真的是个荣幸。这真的是个荣幸。《In Proximity》是 Proximity Media 出品的一档节目。如果你喜欢这个节目，请务必在 Apple Podcasts、Spotify 上关注、评分和评论，
or your favorite podcast app, and tell your friends and loved ones to do the same. If you have someone in your life who you think would like the show, send them a link. To check out Judas in the Black Messiah, the film, and podcast, and 99% invisible, head to proximitymedia.com. We've got links on the show page. Don't forget to follow at Proximity Media on Instagram, Twitter and TikTok. The show is produced by me, Palomato. Executive producers are Ryan Cougler, Zindzi Cougler, Seville Hanyan and me.
或者在你的常用播客应用上关注，并告诉你的朋友和亲人也这样做。如果你生命中有人可能会喜欢这个节目，请把链接发给她。想了解电影《犹大与黑 Messiah》、播客以及《99% Invisible》，请访问 proximitymedia.com。我们在节目页面上提供了链接。别忘了在 Instagram、Twitter 和 TikTok 上关注 @Proximity Media。本节目由我 Palomato 制作。执行制片人是 Ryan Cougler、Zindzi Cougler、Seville Hanyan 和我。
Our theme song and additional music is composed by Ludwig Gorenson. Ken Nana is our sound designer and mix engineer. Paulina Cherasova is our production assistant. Audio editing for this episode is by Sedrick Wilson. Special thanks to the whole proximity media team and to you for listening to Inproximity. It was great, man. I remember that day I came by and got the book and I was kind of like, man, it's so this is where you live, you know what I mean?
我们的主题曲和附加音乐由 Ludwig Gorenson 创作。Ken Nana 是我们的声音设计师和混音师。Paulina Cherasova 是我们的制作助理。本集的音频剪辑由 Sedrick Wilson 负责。特别感谢整个 proximity media 团队，也感谢你们收听《In Proximity》。太棒了，老兄。我记得那天我顺便去拿书的时候，我当时有点像，老兄，这就是你住的地方，你知道我的意思吗？
It was so close. It was like down the street, you know what I mean? We had done all these, all these zooms. It was like, you get this feeling that somebody like halfway across the world, you know what I'm saying? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
离得太近了。就像在街那头，你知道我的意思吗？我们做过所有这些，所有这些 zoom 连线。就会给你一种感觉，就像某人在世界的一半远，你知道我在说什么吗？是的。是的。是的。
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. across the world, you know what I'm saying. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
是的。是的。是的。是的。远在世界的那一端，你知道我在说什么。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。